welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Tony to couple with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we're gonna begin with
the woman who was having an affair with
a Colorado man accused of killing his
fiancee she is expected back on the
stand today after revealing dramatic new
details about the alleged crime
Patrick Frazee is on trial for murder
Frazee's fiance Kelsie Bharath was last
seen in public last Thanksgiving Day her
body has not been found but prosecutors
allege Frazee killed her
Krystal Lee a nurse from Idaho began her
testimony yesterday Niki batiste has
been following this story Nikki good
morning so what did Lee reveal good
morning Tony well there were a few
bombshells during her testimony
including details about the alleged
murder and Kelsie Bharath apparent last
words this is the first time we're
hearing Krystal Lee's story directly
from her there were no cameras allowed
in the Colorado courtroom but all eyes
were still on the Idaho nurse during
most of her testimony she was holding
back tears she was letting tears go CBS
affiliate KKTV reporter Ashley Franco
was in the courtroom Wednesday as
crystal Lee took the stand it looked
like she was giving herself time to get
the answers out but she was definitely
struggling through it Lee was Patrick
Frazee's secret girlfriend she says
Frazee asked her to kill the mother of
his child Kelsie Bharath three times and
when she didn't he did Lee testified
that Frazee told her he beat his fiance
to death with a baseball bat on
Thanksgiving Day and that beareth last
words were please stop
after the murder Lee says Frazee called
her and said she had a mess to clean up
Krystal Lee says when she walked into
Kelsie bear's townhome she saw blood
everywhere she was cleaning up this
massive crime scene Lee claims she drove
from Idaho to Colorado and cleaned up
the crime scene because Frazee told her
to and she feared for her life a few
days after the murder Alise says she
watched his Frazee burned a black tote
bag that he told her contained Beth's
body and the baseball bat more than 20
witnesses have been called to the stand
so far earlier this week a prosecution
expert testified that a neighbour's
survey
once camera captured Frazee 11 times at
Barrett's condo the day she disappeared
the defense argued it's not clear if the
person was Frazee Franco says jurors
have been paying close attention to
everything some of them had their heads
down taking notes you can see on their
faces just the horror and the you know
shock that they were in after hearing
Chris Ali's testimony Frazee has entered
a not guilty plea and faces life in
prison if convicted his defense team is
expected to point the finger at Leigh
during the trial pointing out she lied
before about not knowing phrasing
embarrass in exchange for her testimony
Lee agreed to plead guilty to evidence
tampering she is expected to be back on
the stand later this morning what could
she face right now because she made a
deal with prosecutors for her testimony
she only faces a maximum of three years
in prison but if her story falls apart
that deal is off the table she'll be
sentenced after Patrick frizzies trial
this is so mind-boggling to me and of
course we can't get in Miss Lee's head
and can't judge and don't don't want to
judge but do authorities think she was
afraid for her own safety it doesn't
make sense to me well that's the big
question why would she get in yes but
but crystal Lee says she was fearing for
her own life that Patrick had threatened
her children but we just don't know yet
and it really comes down to what every
Clery believes her thank you